foreign
Affleck and Jennifer Lopez just
celebrated their first Valentine's Day
as husband and wife and marked the
occasion literally with some permanent
body art it's a beautiful moment on
Tuesday JLo posted a few snaps to
Instagram including these throwback pics
with her man and some vacation selfies
but it's these pics that have people
talking that's a triple threat showing
off her newly Inked rib cage it's
exciting zoom in and you'll see the tat
includes a black infinity symbol with an
arrow pointing through the middle and
both Ben and Jen's names
etched in cursive meanwhile Ben opted
for a different design two crossed
Arrows with the letters J and B I've
never seen anything like it Jen
captioned the post quote commitment
along with an infinity symbol and added
Happy Valentine's Day my love I was
super happy the sweet Valentine's Day
moment comes just a few days after the
lovebirds made headlines for their super
cute Super Bowl commercial for Dunkin
Donuts
what are you doing here
Azores previously told ET that the Oscar
winner signed a deal with the coffee and
donut joint worth several million
dollars and in addition to that paycheck
Ben's partnership with Duncan includes a
donation to his non-profit the Eastern
Congo initiative
how's your mother good father all right
it's even better good all right
according to our source Ben planned the
whole commercial and wanted it to feel
like it was shot with a hidden camera I
gotta go guys
grab me a glaze as for benefit our
source says they were so loving on set
what can I tell you we're just having a
good time you can really tell how
special their connection is Jen just
adores Ben and they both lift each other
up and make each other feel so happy
it's really sweet to watch
[Music]